I
hello reg accents Greg here uh hello
rejects it's John here well well well
well well
we're going to be doing a different kind
of reaction today what kind of why am i
I have invented a type of video I'm
calling it an unboxing video no one on
YouTube has ever done this before we're
going to be the first ones ever to have
done this I don't even know what that me
what will chime alright box what was
that you're gonna see us see what's in a
box if we don't know what's in the box
see we got a [ __ ] about we got an
email from from a dick the one email
from the man named Lloyd Christmas man
employed with comic pack that's PA k got
caught up cuz here's exactly what he
said we are a graphic novel subscription
service mommy did it like this make more
fun all we just do every other word duh
oh one that gives people a Marvel DC an
image graphic novel to their door
everyone but one of our biggest passion
is getting people into graphic novel and
reading stories they may not have had
the chance to we love your YouTube
channel and think your audience the end
you would love our comic paku will let
us send you our cover time including
horrible story graphic novels
discredited services so yeah I actually
check out their website this cool
service how much is it a month yeah like
a buck oh yeah lolly months to get $40
or a sector average novel this is deal
how to do it okay so they have two
services here one we have two awesome
graphic novels a month from image and
Marvel DC that's $24.99 a month for
flat-out amazing stories to Marvel DC
and Image Comics every month that's
thirty four nine
I took some time to actually see what
complet graphic novels like these aren't
like a comic book this is a graphic
novel like a full my graphic novel and
they've been like giving I could say two
comics it isn't too tremendous Amanda I
was looking at what they had and I
started rereading some comics started
rereading Batman along Halloween that
like the same day he actually emailed us
and I was like yeah we would love to do
an unboxing video for you guys because
they put in legit graphic novels so here
we go it is an awesome unique packaging
from USPS oh I wonder what that is
United States Postal Service oh no that
tape select a person is select a pod I
was just slide it out so it can have a
little bit of us don't read it don't
burden me to decide yeah people are
going to want proof of their purse April
okay oh they're on a little list of
right that one I have room for me most
these monthly box comes up like it
Lazarus one whew side week Lazarus one
graphic novel it's a real a little bit
of that what you tell us the animation
that's cool whoa first couple pages
there are blood that's a lot of blood
enough like the first pages there's like
no words in here guys you can't see
what's happening yes this is a lot of
violence in here holy [ __ ] I like that
artwork I love it I love it the world
now lies divided not amongst political
or geographic boundaries but amongst
financial ones wealth is power and that
power rests now with only a handful of
families the few who provide a service
for their ruling family are cared for
all others are each family there is one
person given the best they can offer
printing a technology assets every
scientific advantage the person is named
their family's sword and shield their
protector their Lazarus mmm-hmm and the
family Carlyle the Lazarus is called
forever this is the beginning of her
story Oh JA we gotta read this write a
script pitches the Hollywood
what treasure protector huh this guy was
really [ __ ] that looks like Logan
today I knew nothing about this when I
hoped it for you like what is okay Jason
really [ __ ] cool I think I found a
comic to remind you some graphic novel
reviews on the channel now lots of those
plus the next one Cornwall summer garden
heirs of the galaxy New York Times
bestseller this book is apparently
exciting fresh yeah whoa whoa whoa this
is a 2013 edition of guardians of the
galaxy right here know this for $34.99
each like it's really good to be able
for books in here man they're for books
you got your star-lord on the cover you
got Iron Man
you got yondu I think that's good Maura
you got rocky raccoon and you got grew
oh wow this is like guardians origins
Wolverine oh sweet just in time for the
new release of guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 which we will be reviewing this
weekend this is the videos should be
must the video should just be us reading
casually home complex are the one thing
you can read to get
if you go to our patreon you can watch a
full length video this just enjoy
Kannada casually not really showing too
much emotion we got Scotland kickers ooh
this is everyone who loves comics should
buy skull kickers from any cool news
this rowdy actions are as whimsy charm
and wit - mercenaries are entangled and
a high-class assassination plot enough
and nothing werewolf skeletons or black
magic will stop them from getting paid
now I have found neat whoa let's flip
through this well it was a much more
like colourful vibe to it yet the
different animations some it's a
different animation style but it's still
but it's still good bloody it still gets
violent oh man
creatures and she's lauded not long ass
traffic not money pieces it doesn't say
how many pages it is hairy search me get
a postmark for this you get a counter
counting from the top Wow ok this is
cool because there's so many graphic
novels to choose from and I really never
know where to like pick up or start with
mm-hmm and I guess I got a bunch I
haven't read I got like a bunch of em I
read you may choose which comics to put
out based on you know what would kind of
be like popular right now where people
form the sort of reading into right now
so this can help me keep up with the
times it's the last one day help let's
see what it is here we go
ding justice hell yeah
gods among us volume I played the video
game that's a lie I watched the story
mode on tuber they put all the movie
footage on YouTube and I loved it I
loved it I was I watched the whole thing
in like one night only game I've ever
done that for it's fantastic oh it's
crap I could actually read the comment
down in justice God and justice 2 is
coming out in just a couple weeks
perfect where there's a hard yeah did I
get stuck I guess I didn't even see what
this wave I know that to be the last
what this just happened to be the last
something told me to grab that one
for that one holy crab I can actually
reveal gee comic now okay I'm the only
Gadsden I might actually review this one
on the channel this one I might actually
if you guys want that will I'll
definitely do it so speak up because
your opinion this is so cool
oh man because I never got to do a
review of the video game because I don't
do that
but to be able to like actually review
like Volume one of the comic Oh Lucius
it's based on the hit video game
interesting is in Reverse I thought this
was the source mature I know you read
this your view game oh yeah oh yeah this
is this this is worth this was worth
embossing everything I'm definitely
starting with this one
I think the order I would go in is
injustice
Lazarus guardians of the galaxy and then
sculling kickers but it hadn't just this
comic book I'm gonna I'm probably gonna
read through this like a knight really
soon hell yeah guys go check out comic
background comments wanna tell you we
missed out on the month of forward they
actually gave that old man Logan what I
learned it's so cool right yeah we
missed out on that however this is still
really well worth it I'm glad to add to
my collection for Wednesday on nerd
friends come over and they think I'm
just as up-to-date with them yeah you
can really call me few oh well great
Sweden arenas must've had an image books
over got some of Lazarus one an order
the reply sir is what did I must be
interested beyond that
another Lazarus one looks really cool
yeah I should read it write the script
teach it to Hollywood Hollywood there
you go just put it on every doorstep at
all someone's bound to be like yeah I
got nothing else to do I'm gonna read
this your scripts will just do it like
in Breaking Bad when Jesse Pinkman
couldn't live with the money and he just
starts throwing it at people's doors
make copies of our scriptures sorry
throw it yeah here you go someone thinks
it's a good idea this is good and take
it to Hollywood all right Comic Con
techcom thanks for sending this our way
link in description box to go to their
site you can subscribe to the real
rejects he's reasons to Jerry on Twitter
and to have social media manager of Blum
house and the real rejects that's what
does that mean that means he's in charge
of all the posts that go up there
so he's sharing a part of himself with
you guys to go check out our patreon and
click that notification though follow us
on social media
knotti does that so let's do solid with
here follow look there what out of the
day three is ended the [ __ ] video